[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and we're honored to have
renowned artist Sougwen Chung
here to talk about her work.
Welcome.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Hi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now
I've been looking
forward to your
performance here at I/O.
And I'd like to talk about it.
But first how about
some background?
When did you start working
with robots and why?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: That's
a great question.
I get asked that all the time.
I started working with
robots about five years ago.
I've been kind of
a digital nomad.
I learned to code when
I was quite young.
And I got really
interested in ways
to take what's present inside
the simulation of the computer
into the physical world.
So I started with a really
simple drawing collaboration
with my first robotic arm.
And it's just taken
off ever since.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How has
the experience of, say,
human machine
collaboration changed
your process as an artist?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: You know,
I think about that a lot.
Because I think it has changed
it quite significantly.
I've gotten more accustomed
to chaos, to put it mildly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Things going
not the way you expect?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, there's
a lot of erratic emergent
behavior or assigned
attributed behavior
to working with these
machines that really got me
outside of my comfort
zone from just
my simple drawing practice.
I think there's something
really gestural and cognitive
about mark making.
That when you do that with a
robotic articulated unit it--
yeah, there's a lot
of new surprises.
I'd like to think of
working with these machines
as a creative catalyst.
So that ends up being
quite inspiring for me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Interesting.
All right, let's talk about
the performance a little bit.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Sure, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, it
was beautiful and elegant.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
expected that part, right?
Because I looked at
your work online.
What I didn't expect was
something completely different.
That your relationship
with the robots felt--
if I can say--
gentle and familial,
like they were family.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, they
pretty much are at this point.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean,
tell me about that.
How much of what you're
doing about the art
is about that relationship
rather than the marks
that you're making?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, definitely.
So I implicate the
tool as a collaborator.
And I think I frame
it as a collaboration
because we want to facilitate
kind, generous collaborations
in the world between
humans to humans.
And I think when I regard these
machines as my collaborators
it's a way of just creating
a more empathetic model.
In this context it's
behavioral empathy.
But when I'm onstage
performing with these robots
I think it's very much me and
them and this captive audience.
And that mutual
reliance and co-creation
ends up spurring a very
emotional connection with them.
And I think that we've evolved--
like, my process has
evolved significantly
with this collaborative work.
And they have as well.
I think it's a positive way
of slanting anthropomorphism
that's just been really
inspiring for the work.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Did
you have to do anything
to build that relationship
like hanging out
with them outside of work?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, we get a
few beers every now and then.
Honestly there's so much
vitality and vulnerability when
doing these performances that
we've kind of been in this
together-- with the risk
of sounding a bit cheesy--
has made it feel like a
really close connection.
In addition to the
robotic arms I've
been designing a multi-robotic
system that's actually
a series of 20
painting robots that
also is a articulation
of this robotic form
in a different way.
Instead of one to
one it's one to many.
And that is a totally
different relationship.
It's almost like a natural swarm
that I'm really excited about.
So that reframes the
relationship too.
And it's like embodied
kinetic sculpture.
That's only possible
in today's moment.
And that really excites me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
the themes of the work
that you performed here.
Mimicry, memory, and
future speculations.
How did you land on those?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: So the mimicry
was the first generation.
I call my robots Doug.
Because the project is named--
let's just drop the formalities
and call them what they are.
I started the project and it's
called Drawing Operations Unit
Generation One was
focused on mimicry.
And that was DOUG One.
And it's sort of
grown over time.
It's mimicry, memory,
and future speculations
because those are the three
chapters of this evolving
generational project.
So I'm really excited
about the third.
Because it shows
multi-robotic collaboration
alongside my human
drawing agency.
And that's very much
where the work is headed.
Towards a more collaborative,
more collective idea.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is there
a fourth generation
you have in mind?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah, there is.
Well, the third
generation is actually
the multi-robotic system
which is the painting ones.
But there's a fourth generation
that I can't talk about yet.
But it'll be coming soon.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome,
well I look forward to it.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Yeah,
I'm excited to share it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The score
for the work by Aquarian.
How did that contribute
to the raw work.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: It
contributed so much.
Aquarian has been a good friend
of mine for quite a while.
And does some incredible
music that is actually quite--
it's brilliant.
I think I was describing it
earlier as it's futuristic
but also taps into this
nostalgia about jungle and drum
and bass that's really,
really interesting.
I sort of asked him to come
up with the score for me.
And discussed with him
about the themes I'd
like him to interpret.
So he really came up with
a beautiful, melodic work
that really adds so
much to the piece.
We were really excited
to collaborate with
and use the 40 sound
system from Monome
and spatialize this work.
One component of the
performance that we did--
especially for I/O-- was the
integration of a contact mic
component.
So in the beginning
my drawing gestures
actually form architectural
sound throughout the space.
And it was really cool
to control the universe
of the performance like that.
So we were very excited about
it and hope to do again soon.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
OK, one more question--
and I have to ask this.
What's the biggest surprise
your robot partner has ever
given you in a performance?
SOUGWEN CHUNG: I like
your verbiage with that.
Because I do think
about it as giving
of the artistic behavior.
I think it's been
incredibly surprising.
I think one of the reasons I've
been working with neural nets
is its native
ability to generate
non-human, unexpected behaviors.
It's been a really interesting
way of looking at my own work.
Because I train all my neural
nets on my own drawings
to re-examine the
type of work I do.
And see how it feels to
be articulated by a unit.
So I think it's
constantly surprising me.
Which is probably not the
answer you're looking for.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't know,
I think that's a great answer.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: I
will say what I do
find surprising about the duets
is not only the robot's output,
but the response to it has
been really interesting.
And it's really taken off a
lot of speculative questions
about technology and philosophy.
And sort of what it means to
make work as an artist today.
So that's been the most
surprising connection
that this performance
has created for me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you for that.
And thanks for sharing your
vision and your art with us
here at I/O '19.
SOUGWEN CHUNG: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]